[Music]
and don't know don't care news don't
know that's like that's the way to live
that's me
submitted by a fan from Antarctica oh
yeah I was just saying the other day
that I always forget about that how
[ __ ] dare you
there's a hole there you could get to
the center of the earth
oh yeah to the earth center that world
in the center uh it's a conspiracy
oh do people actually live in Antarctica
there's a space station or something
there
oh no there's a there's a joint station
I guess there's one to live live there's
always a bigger person purposely search
station Eskimos or some [ __ ] there
that's a last Alaska with Santa and
Eskimos Amazon doesn't care if you
accidentally shoplift from its Amazon go
locations what why don't they say that
this is Amazon go I'm gonna show you
guys good little video of what Enron go
is and then with this Amazon's like we
make so much money we don't get hey
cards should I take it
Grima Korea welcome to Amazon go
and use the Amazon Go app to enter then
put away your phone and start shopping
it's really that simple
take whatever you like that's it of
course all right automatically added to
your virtual cart oh my mind about that
cupcake just put it back there's the
[ __ ] future don't get your virtual
card automatically
eyes mind blown out at work we used
computer vision deep learning algorithms
at sensor fusion much like you'd find in
self-driving cars we call it just walk
out technology that's a crappy unit once
you've got everything you want you can
just go when you leave our just walk out
technology adds up your virtual cart and
charges your Amazon account your receipt
ascend straight to the app and you can
keep going
Amazon go that's [ __ ] say you know
what the crappy thing about that is for
consumers you're gonna be [ __ ] broke
my voice during all this [ __ ] that's
exactly how those [ __ ] sound by the
way I don't know what you're talking
about
gonna make you fun of them about his
voice yeah that was videos ago nobody
knows what we're talking ever remember
when you make money please take it back
yeah
oh I'm gonna get you taken back I'm so
sick now you don't there's no more lines
at supermarkets that's awesome you know
that's funny
so someone tweeted this up they said I'm
in Seattle and there is currently a line
to shop at the grocery store everyone
everyone's going like whoa check it out
you don't mean like they're all making
videos of themselves at Amazon Gus
you know what's even better than that
just [ __ ] having it work to your door
yeah instacart pretty [ __ ] but I do
think there's something about being able
to check something that oh yeah certain
stuff because I like to think that I'm
an expert even though I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm doing yeah I mean so when
you buy toilet paper no you know what I
want to do sometimes you know when
you're at the the [ __ ] fruit stand
and clearly this guy has never cooked in
his life whereas touches the fruit
before let me go
some welcome to him do you really know
what you're looking at absolutely not
when I meant the grocery store this
lady's like looking at tomatoes and
she's like no and I'm like just [ __ ]
pick a tomato can I do what tomatoes I
look at it oh no bugs no bucks
let me go write it I don't even look at
it and then I go home and I'm like oh
I throw away like a whole bag of onions
oh yeah this shit's scary man it's very
scary because it's like like I feel like
during the video like he's such positive
inflection is you know it's like it's
like how do we do it it's like we
drilled into your brain silly yeah feels
like it's like a sci-fi movie and you
know they have like psychologists that
help them trigger you're like desires
and like they know what you want and
then they're like oh this will make them
you know want to buy the cake and yeah
this will tickle their balls a little
bit but were the old people right now do
you realize that do you hear yourself
where the old people complain anybody
I'm not in that not me it's gonna be
cool no lines I what do you need to zoom
ins on your phone for don't you just
make a call with like that kind of [ __ ]
when iPhones gonna man those guys
[ __ ] take the real interesting Hill
to die on I don't know I think cuz we
have foresight and we're ready like that
actually thing yeah you never tradition
no you're in the Marines either that's
actual sorry did I make military that is
to why for me that's a white tank I pick
a hill Diane yeah big in the hell did I
make a hell to die on
yeah that's there's no other you try to
say with the accent to see if it's even
more Asian honky yeah pick a hail to die
on man pick a Hilton I'll make a hell to
die even tips heard of it that's crazy I
mean it's over and that's pretty Mexican
over there huh south of the borders you
can go so what does that figure of
speech mean well it's like if you decide
like you're coming to this argument
that's the hill that you're gonna it's
like when I I've been against the growth
right like I was against selfies when
selfies first book coming out or
whatever [ __ ] [ __ ] and I was like
I'll never take no selfies let me tell
you something this selfie thing and I
lost I died on that hill like everyone
in the world takes selfies like [ __ ]
5 billion people take selfies like I was
an idiot for you up them though cuz not
only do you take the selfie you add a
million filter but you know you know I
picked that hill and I died on that no
way but I feel like in California like
California white people don't use as
many of those like colloquial phrases as
people outside of California yeah cuz I
don't hear it as much until those
[ __ ] colloquial
casual casual sex thank you I say [ __ ]
like Hilda Dyer now you say some white
people yes there was this CNBC tech
correspondent she ended up walking out
of the Amazon ghost or she said I think
I just shoplifted hashtag Amazon go
didn't charge me for my siggy you
yoghurt hashtags no lines no check out
hashtag free stuff yeah what if you go
in there I'm not even a customer oh you
don't even have the app right you have
to you have to have as a bouncer well
yeah didn't you see the little it only
allows one person at a time
well that turn think it's pretty easy to
go over so and one of those [ __ ]
lines then actually no it's not a turn a
turnstile yeah but that I could walk
through that that's like how I got to
pay for so there will be lines I I
thought it was one big open door I don't
like to shop at stores but I like to
window shop at stores so if I have to go
to a grocery stop to go shopping I get
anxiety but if I'm going there to check
out the new products I have fun what new
products do you get it like sometimes
they got cool bacon flavor okay you know
like there's just different stuff yeah a
new bacon flavors you ever heard of they
should be making [ __ ] dare you doubt
him first of all you don't like so you
know foods is like really really next
level it's expensive it's got some cool
new stuff but I was always too poor to
like shop at hold on anymore yeah but I
would like to go and just check out the
kind of cool [ __ ] that they go shit's
like normal price now it's cool we're
definitely the old people cuz if this
[ __ ] were [ __ ] talking about going to
a grocery store to see the new [ __ ] that
they have you know what the scam is for
host of Whole Foods though they charge
regular prices but that [ __ ] goes old
real quick cuz there's no preservatives
it's all fresh yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] did I
want my [ __ ] covered in wax thank you I
need preservatives cuz I'm not gonna get
to it and have you had an organic apple
they lit no taste anywhere near as good
as the wax covered apples I'll tell you
that
you don't mean like some of this shit's
way better yeah I can't tell the
difference bell peppers
I can't tell the difference except that
one bell peppers like six times the size
of the other one and which one are you
to go for the biggest one
thank you get the [ __ ] value please
cuz you see this bigger and it's 99
cents this one's a buck [ __ ] 59 and
it's smaller I think I'll pick the
bigger one thank you and that's why I
brought dieing so far but I don't give a
[ __ ] but it's hard to buy organic cuz
it's so [ __ ] expensive because I've
been shopping more cuz I've been cooking
more and homies [ __ ] and they had this
one small little organic section why is
it more expensive like does it mean more
to do less dude scientifically and feel
free to correct me it's easily to mass
these are mass produced no no
scientifically do the same [ __ ] thing
right seriously and what do you mean by
scientifically I mean like if you took
both of the whatever the products right
you put them side-by-side like they've
done studies all the [ __ ] right they're
the same like physiologically the same
why don't you like to utilize well I'd
like ones grown organically right and
the other ones grown and laughs well
they're under the same conditions are
the same like the chemical makeup that
type of stuff the whole thing's a same
there's no the whole thing about it is
mostly tied into pesticides and all that
stuff but even that stuff is not harmful
like they all thought it was 30 years
how hard is it to get rid of a pesticide
from your green bell pepper
cuz I'm thinking if I just put some
water on it I'm fine you can black what
is it called blanching Oh like a hot
water like five seconds because let me
tell you what I do to watch my fruit I
take the fruit I eat all the fruit and
then I drink a glass of water just one
straight line in a big-ass [ __ ] and
my thing is to like if I put that green
bell pepper in a [ __ ] hot wok and it
survives
5000 degrees it deserves to live I allow
you to live inside my body it's all
making sense okay with all these people
here the difference between a commercial
farming and an organic farming is the
way that it destroys the soil so in
commercial farming it's usually like one
crop and they don't rotate it so what
happens is the soil is depleted yeah of
nutrients so they have to put new camera
and things into the soil and then but
with organic farming typically they do
multi crop kind of things so then it
keeps it all like intact and it doesn't
rip up the soil and [ __ ] it up and it
didn't have to put new [ __ ] in the soil
so that's that's that's the main thing
just but then a lot of people are
twisting and saying like if you do
organic then it's healthier or whatever
yeah they say the same [ __ ] about
organic soap and guess what all those
people smell like [ __ ] oh actually you
know what back to your commercially
grown bell pepper and then the organic I
just remember why you're supposed to go
with organic one because in nature you
want genetic variation to be healthy but
for them they usually they just find the
King Kong of bell peppers and they just
reproduce that so you're not getting
like a variety in the diet there's
actually better to have various oh that
case what you want them you want the red
one the iron King Kong a bell peppers
that's all I'm saying yeah so there was
an Amazon rep responded to that woman
that definitely still from us I dare you
first and foremost enjoyed the yogurt on
us accidental shoplifting happen soro
rarely that we didn't even bother
building in a feature for customers to
tell us it happened Wow
that's cocky as [ __ ] well they actually
do that and on their online shopping
experience you know if they accidentally
send you to an eagle hey you set me to
the girl just keep it no no I'm just
saying it's it's cocky and bold because
they're just like we got this [ __ ] down
on log dude you don't even need we don't
have I know you were cheating on me but
I knew you was cheating on me in the
first play that sauce [ __ ] this other
[ __ ]
[Music]